hello everyone and welcome to the
mindscape podcast I'm your host Sean
Carroll and today we have another
episode of quantum mechanics I know this
makes everyone very excited today I'm
talking to Adam Becker who is a PhD in
physics but has gone the route of
becoming a freelance science writer and
most interestingly for our current
purposes he's the author of a book
called what is real this is a really
wonderful book I've been recommending it
right and left it's about the history of
quantum mechanics in the 20th century
but it's not the typical history most
histories of quantum mechanics focus on
from 1900 to 1935 and what Adam really
does is look at what happens after 1935
he does a little bit of the early stuff
but the point is that as I talked about
in my own book something deeply hidden
there's this weird thing where quantum
mechanics is invented it comes with this
giant problem called the measurement
problem what really happens when you
measure a quantum system why do the
rules seem to be different etc and then
after a very brief flurry of interest in
talking about the measurement problem
with people like Bohr and Heinz Stein
and Schrodinger going back and forth
it's forgotten
it's just dropped it is in fact becomes
it becomes disreputable to even think
about the measurement problem so atom
really digs into the history of the
people who refused to be quieted when
talking about this huge problem in
physics the plucky band of rebels who
really said no actually this is kind of
an important thing need to think about
it so he talks about Hugh Everett of
course but also David Bohm John bel a
lot of the experimentalists like clauser
and osprey and others who really tackled
this problem and tried to remind the
physics community that despite what
their advisors told them the measurement
problem in quantum mechanics is really
really important so it's not about here
solving the measurement problem it's
sort of about the history of how
physicists talked about that problem and
it's a fascinating history with colorful
characters so you'll both learn a little
bit about quantum mechanics but also
learn a little bit about the history and
sociology of physics which is really
much more fascinating than it has any
right to be
so let's go
[Music]
Adam Becker welcome to the mindscape
podcast well thanks for having me it's
great to be here of course this is a
slightly unusual show just because
they're all slightly unusual I don't
know I keep saying that quantum
mechanics I should say this is a
slightly usual show the single topic I
do the most cuz I'm coming out with a
book on quantum mechanics short now I do
quantum mechanics for living but you've
written a book that's already out about
quantum mechanics so for the purposes of
this interview I'm gonna pretend that I
don't know much try to get it out from
you sure and specifically is it okay to
characterize your book as a history of
quantum mechanics yeah I think that's
that's what it is yeah it's it's
definitely a history of quantum
mechanics it is I would say somewhat
unusual history of quantum mechanics and
I think it's a good history of cloth but
I'm biased well it's a it's unusual I
guess you're gonna say that in a sense
that you know history there's a set of
things that happen but you have an angle
right here you have a theme I have an
angle that's one of the things that
makes it unusual in that I think that
the sort of dominant take on what
quantum mechanics says this thing that's
called the Copenhagen interpretation but
also goes by other names like the
Orthodox interpretation or whatever I am
NOT a fan to put it mildly the other
thing though that I think makes my book
somewhat unusual is a history of quantum
mechanics is you know there are a lot of
other popular histories of quantum
mechanics out there and most of them
sort of start in say 1900 with Max
Planck and them may say you know Max
Planck found the blackbody radiation law
and that was the beginning of the
quantum revolution and then they sort of
moved forward from that with Einstein
and the photoelectric effect in Bohr and
his model of the atom and then you know
they they end with and then Heisenberg
and Schrodinger developed you know fully
fledged modern quantum mechanics and
everybody lived happily ever after and
then maybe you know Einstein and Bohr
got into a fight but Bohr one and then
you know thirty years later John Bell
did a thing and that
the end of the book right my book kind
of inverts that structure I only have a
chapter or two at the beginning about
the very early days of quantum mechanics
and most of the book focuses on stuff
that happened from say 1945 onward
actually is fascinating so just just so
there's if there's any people out there
in the audience who think quantum
mechanics is fun but history is not it's
really really illuminating to go through
this particular kind of history because
you see where people got certain
attitudes and you know quantum mechanics
is hardened and it shows us a lot about
physics and the physics community right
yeah yeah I mean I think I think that
there is general attitude or idea among
some physicists and some scientists of
various stripes that history and
personalities and culture don't really
matter that much in science and and
aren't really reflected in science and
that's just kind of wrong it's just
objective truth that and what are you
talking yeah I find the truth we lay it
out there for people
yeah that's clearly true sciences of
body effects it's not a human process
yeah but science is a human process
right and it's affected by all other
human processes right which is not to
say that science is just you know
[ __ ] that people make up well we
certainly make choices along the way
about how didyou science right what's
important what questions we're gonna
tackle and so forth and quantum
mechanics is a great example so why
don't we well we wanted to give your
version of what is quantum mechanics oh
boy quantum mechanics is a phenomenally
successful physical theory it is it is
the best theory we have to account for
the behavior and predict the behavior of
very small objects but also things that
are constituted of very small objects
which is basically everything and so so
quantum mechanics so one one definition
of quantum mechanics is it is well hold
on quantum physics right yeah quantum
mechanics we usually use that for
non relativistic theory but but but
anyway yeah quantum physics because it's
this theory for tiny things and things
made of tiny things which is everything
it's basically our best physical theory
of everything with a little asterisk on
it and the asterisk is general
relativity which is a whole other thing
but basically anything that where
gravity doesn't matter that much we're
that much means matters less than it
does I don't know inside of the heart of
a dense star or near a black hole
quantum mechanics is fantastic okay what
does it actually say what is it let's
imagine someone is listening who just
doesn't know about uncertainty or wave
functions or anything like that yeah
well that's the question right
I mean quantum mechanics is so one way
of answering the question is quantum
mechanics this is a really good
mathematical tool for predicting the
outcomes of experiments and predicting
you know how various physical phenomena
will play out as for what it tells us is
going on in the world that's a question
of interpreting the mathematical
structure and the results of the
experiments that we do and that's
exactly what's at stake in the story
that I'm telling in my book you know the
the question of how to interpret this
incredibly successful theory to figure
out what it's telling us about the world
is very controversial and has been since
the early days of quantum mechanics back
in the 1920s and even before I mean
that's why I don't think we've actually
said the name of my book yet but that's
that's why the title of my book is what
is real question mark right it's it's
it's not a finished story and that
question is the question you know at
hand so yeah you do notice this whenever
you're trying to talk about whenever I'm
trying to talk about quantum mechanics
is that you can't say anything about
what the theory says without choosing a
formulation of it right without
downsides in these interpretation Wars
exactly yeah I mean you know I could I
could say something that would make you
as a many-worlds person very happy and
say well quantum mechanics
tells us that things can be in more than
one place at once in different universes
and very small systems composed of a
very small number of things can
interfere with their counterparts and
other universes but then when you get
large aggregate number of things that
doesn't happen as much unless you
perform special tricks that would make a
lot of people very angry if I said that
that was what quantum mechanics said
without qualification right oh don't
worry I've no trouble making people
angry there are a lot of people angry
with me well why don't we just be a
little bit historical and imagine that
we are there at the Solveig conference
international for those of you who don't
know this was this 1927 I think yes
like it was it was the moment when
quantum mechanics sort of matured
yeah and all the bright bright people in
the physics world were there and they
headed out and tempers flare exactly
yeah no this this was I don't know we're
in LA it was the Oscars of quantum
mechanics right so yeah yeah there were
this was this was a major major
conference in 1927 in Belgium and all of
the key players in the formulation of
quantum mechanics are almost all of them
were there so yeah so for example Albert
Einstein was there Niels Bohr the great
Danish physicist was there Louie de boy
was there Verner Heisenberg was there or
when Schrodinger was there Max Born
yeah plunk was there Holly Marie Curie
Dirac yeah like everybody was there I
think Rutherford was there like everyone
was there and this was sort of a great
coming-out party for the the version of
quantum mechanics or the way of thinking
about quantum mechanics that Heisenberg
and born and Bohr and Polly had sort of
cobbled together which is not to say
that those four were the only ones
involved nor is it to say those four all
agreed with each other but they agreed
and
that that they were able to put together
a presentation that they gave and and
specifically presentation that Bourne
and Heisenberg I believe gave in in
which they said okay here's the theory
here's how it works it's done it's a
complete theory and you can't add
anything to it and it doesn't let you
say anything about what's going on
before you take a measurement and this
is what we call it the Copenhagen
interpretation of the Copenhagen
interpretation agrees Olimpica yeah
nobody that that's the other thing but
yes so what we teach our students today
we teach our students something that
plausibly goes by that name I mean cuz
cuz there's you know here's another way
of answering your your earlier question
of what quantum mechanics is and then
I'll get back to the Solveig conference
quantum mechanics is a pair of rules for
predicting what's going to happen in the
world one of the rules is this thing
called the Schrodinger equation which is
exactly the kind of thing that we love
to have us a law of nature it is
deterministic it's a beautiful partial
differential equation it's very very
pretty it says that there are these
things in the world or that there are
things whether they're in the world so
are there things there are things called
wave functions and as the name sort of
implies they kind of wave and you know
they they undulate in a way that is
perfectly predictable through the
beautiful mathematics of the Schrodinger
equation and then there's this other
thing called the born rule and the born
rule doesn't look like a normal normal
law of nature it doesn't look like the
laws of nature that physicists were
accustomed to in the 1920s which is not
in and of itself a strike against it
that's fine it's right we could be
dramatic and knew that exactly that's
good you know or can be good but the
born rule also Max Born not the concept
of being born that's true yes named
after max born the same way that the
Schrodinger equation is named after her
when Schrodinger and to give credit
it's due Heisenberg came up with
something sort of like the Schrodinger
equation it was something that was
mathematically equivalent but Max Born
he said okay these wave functions there
is another way that they behave they
when you when you look at something that
has a wave function associated with it
or when you take a measurement of
something that has a wave function
associated with it which is supposed to
be everything in quantum mechanics that
wave function collapses it goes to zero
everywhere except in one spot or in one
spot like in one spot or in one way yeah
one value everything everything but one
value goes to zero and which one it's
going to be is probabilistic which one
is going to not be zero is probabilistic
and you can determine that by looking at
the values of the wave function the
moment before you make the measurement
and the problem is that these two rules
for how wave functions work contradict
each other and so there's the question
when do you use one and when do you use
the other one so one rule for when
you're not looking at it yes another
rule for when you are yes something like
that and so the the question the
question is which one do you use when
and the traditional answer the
Copenhagen answer is to say oh you use
the born rule this collapse rule when
you're looking at things when you're
making a measurement and use the
Schrodinger equation for when you're not
looking what do we mean by looking
what's a measurement what counts as a
measurement who has to do it right do
you need a PhD to do a measurement what
if you just glance at what if you just
glanced at it what if a monkey does it
what if a bacterium does it all these
questions so this this sort of assorted
host of questions that go along with
this one core question of which rule do
we use when that's the measurement
problem right the measurement problem of
quantum mechanics yeah and the
Copenhagen interpretation has claims to
have a solution to this
claves have many solutions to this
because the Copenhagen interpretation
isn't any one thing but the Solveig
conference the solution that was
proposed was it's not right it's not
good scientific practice to talk about
what's going on when you're not looking
so the philosophical maneuver that they
made yes something along those lines and
not everyone was happy with this in
particular Albert Einstein was very
unhappy with this and so he starts
getting into it with Niels Bohr in
particular but really the rest of them
as well he proposes a couple of thought
experiments to try to get around this to
show why this can't quite be right or at
least can't be the whole story
he is misunderstood basically right off
the bat and this goes on for years well
there's this popular idea that Einstein
just couldn't handle or couldn't keep up
with quantum mechanics yeah and that's
it's such a strange myth because the
opposite of true yeah it's the opposite
of true which which usually we call that
false but it I mean Einstein first of
all was one of the founders of quantum
mechanics you know his 1905 paper on the
photoelectric effect postulated the
existence of you know quantized packets
of light photons and and that's hardly
the only work he did on quantum
mechanics throughout his career he did a
lot of very very important work on
quantum mechanics both before and after
they're probably less after the the full
modern formulation of quantum mechanics
shows up in the mid 1920s there is no
evidence whatsoever that he couldn't
keep up with it
he definitely understood it he spent a
lot of time thinking about it he once
said that he spent more time thinking
about quantum mechanics or I think the
phrase was that he used up more brain
grease on quantum mechanics than he did
on relativity which is what he's more
known for I mean he'll he he got the
Nobel Prize for his work on quantum
mechanics not for his work on relativity
which is a weird
historical quirk and Nobel Prizes aren't
that important anyway but but yes upset
and I think it makes perfect sense if if
you don't know a lot about quantum
mechanics I think you should sympathize
with why he was upset at the Solvay
conference both because there are these
two different rules that you use under
different circumstances and just because
it all seemed so ill-posed right like
yeah the whole point of physics is to be
precise and beautiful and exact and this
hand wavy thing about making
measurements somehow sneaked in yeah
yeah I mean he Ernst eyeing Einstein had
a what was at the time a fairly common
sense view of what physics was about he
said physics is about describing what's
in the world and now you're telling me
no physics is about predicting the
outcomes of experiments what's an
experiment what you know if it's really
only about predicting the outcomes of
experiments then how are we supposed to
use it to explain things that happen in
the natural world when we're not around
which people were doing already at the
time you know quantum mechanics has
always been used to do more than just
predict the outcomes of experiments it
has also been used to explain all kinds
of very you know interesting natural
phenomena ranging from stuff as basic as
you know why does the Sun Shine to you
know why is it that silicon behaves in
this funny way where it's not really an
insulator it's not really a conductor
it's a semi conductor right yeah and
that lets us build computers you know so
everything from basic fundamental facts
about the world around us like you know
why I I can't pass my hand through the
table to you know you know all sorts of
strange and wonderful modern technology
like LEDs or most of this recording
equipment and I thought you know you
mentioned this very quickly but I want
to dwell on this philosophical leap made
by the Copenhagen interpretation so I
really say that the job of your physical
theory in this case is to simply predict
the outcomes of experiments
and they said this the the advocates of
Copenhagen as far as I can tell we're
sometimes more explicit about this than
others they were never completely on the
same page but okay there there's a
version of it which really says that and
it's almost solipsistic idealistic and
if you really push it you're saying it's
all in the mind
right you thing like the the world as
something that exists external to me is
irrelevant to physics when what is
important to physics is the predictions
that I can make in the observations that
I can make yeah yeah I mean I think I
think that that is definitely one way to
take what they were saying
you know I I don't think that there is
any single Copenhagen interpretation and
and while Niels Bohr and Max Born and
Howley and Heisenberg and the others may
have each had their own individual
positions I don't think that you can
combine all of those to make something
coherent and in some cases like with
Niels Bohr it's not even clear what each
individual's position was yeah there's
there's no consensus within one paper
exactly yeah yeah I mean III speaking of
people being mad at me this is something
that some people are mad at me for they
say but you said that Niels Bohr had
this position like no I didn't I didn't
say that Niels Bohr had any position I
don't know what position he had neither
does anybody else I just quoted him a
few times because like if you try to
translate what he says or paraphrase
yeah people gonna be mad at ya exactly
no it's it's he's he was a brilliant
physicist and a very interesting man who
did lots of wonderful things and he just
was not a particularly clear writer or
speaker
well David Albert when I interviewed him
for the podcast he had a wonderful take
on Niels Bohr he said the Niels Bohr was
the person in history who he would most
like to have met personally yeah reason
why is because you know people would
meet him and they would come back after
talking to Niels Bohr and number one
they would say this was the most
brilliant wonderful transcendentally
wise human being and they would start
spouting complete nonsense
how can one person have this effect ya
know it's it's a real question I mean I
don't know I I don't know if he's the
person in history I'd most like to
invite to dinner but I'm certainly very
curious about it when I consider
potential sponsors for mindscape I'm
naturally drawn to educational services
but policy genius can be thought of as
an educational service when it comes
time to search for insurance policies
whether it's life insurance home
insurance auto insurance you go to the
website and you can find multiple quotes
from the leading insurers around the
country so you can pick which is the
policy that best fits you there at the
right price they do not add cost to the
insurance policies that you'd be signing
up for they simply get a commission from
the different companies that are selling
them and so you can look at all the
different policies what they involve and
pick the one that is best for you what I
really like is that you don't need to
tell them your contact info first you
don't need to give them your name or
email before they give you the quote
they also have experts on staff who can
help you search through all of these
different policies so when you make
insurance choices just like when you do
anything else it's best to be educated
and at policy genius.com that's what
you'll be but they did win the PR battle
yesterday after Solvay it's more or less
became standard conventional wisdom that
the Copenhagen interpretation was how we
think about quantum mechanics and there
were a few people who didn't like that
like Einstein also fertig er yeah that's
right
the day's became increasingly
marginalized at least in terms of how we
think about quantum mechanics yeah
that's exactly right yeah they you know
people thought Einstein the Schrodinger
were kind of out of touch and kooky and
maybe they were kooky but they were not
wrong I think do you have doubts about
this but you know their work was
increasingly outside of the mainstream
of the work that the rest of the physics
community was engaging in not not in the
sense that oh it was wrong or fringe but
in that the rest of the physics
community was just not thing
about these things they were working on
other things and part of that was for
you know really obvious historical
reasons right this debate was going on
in the early to mid 1930s mostly in
Europe there were some things also going
on in the 1930s in her up into the 40s
that were somewhat distracting to a lot
of people and physicists in particularly
yes they did yeah so you know by the
1940s people were working on other
things such as the Manhattan Project and
so and then and then after the Manhattan
Project after the war suddenly there was
this realization due to you know the the
I hesitate to use the word success for
the Manhattan Project but due to the
achievements of the Manhattan Project
there was recognition by governments and
industry and the military that there was
a lot of value to be had in funding
massive amounts of Applied Physics and
so rather than worrying about the
foundations of quantum mechanics this
this influx of money and the people who
came along with that were concerned with
working out implications of quantum
physics which is a good thing to do you
know there was a lot of really really
great science done in that period and
and I do think that if the attitude had
been okay you know what there's a
problem here at the foundations we'll
come back to it later there's something
that we need to figure out but in the
meantime we have a lot of really
interesting work to do and maybe that'll
help us understand the theory better and
that will shed more light on things if
that had been the attitude I wouldn't
have had a book to write yeah because
that and I think that's a very sensible
attitude there have been many other
theories in the history of science that
have worked that way you know Newton
himself right talked about his own
theories in this way sometimes but
that's not what happened sorry that's
not what happened instead it was oh
those problems are solved
we don't have to worry about the
foundations now we can you know work on
these applications
of the theory and the foundations we
mean is the correct attitude towards
this measurement problem really just to
only ask about measurement outcomes or
is there some other version of quantum
mechanics some other way of thinking
about things that is more traditionally
physically scientific exactly yeah I
mean the with this influx of money and
people that came after world war ii
questions like but what does the theory
mean were kind of swept under the rug
and there was this there's been a lot of
really good work on how the changes in
physics after World War Two led to
changes in the way that quantum
mechanics was taught that's been done by
the historian of science David Kaiser at
MIT who you know has gone back through
physics curricula and textbooks from the
time and found that the larger the
classroom the less time spent on you
know the meaning and foundations of the
theory and the more time spent on
applications and I think that makes
sense you know it's easier to teach
people how to solve a different partial
differential equation than it is to you
know talk about these thorny
philosophical issues at the heart of the
theory so I do think that we're gonna
get look we'll get to the you know
plucky band of robots did want to keep
thinking about the foundation a little
bit a death star let's I mean let me try
since my usual spiel is what a huge
mistake it was to ignore the foundations
yeah let's try to be charitable sure to
the people who did ignore the foundation
absolutely as you said there's a lot of
Applied Physics to do there was even non
applied physics sure and when Murray
gell-mann is working out you know the
su3 symmetry group the Eightfold way
absolute locations of this ya military
or anything like that but so what would
someone back then have said if you said
why aren't you thinking about quantum
mechanics as a foundational theory well
I think
I think that answers would have varied
right one answer that someone could have
given was but we are you know take a
look at I think this is the late 1940s
early 1950s speaking of non applied
foundational work of a different kind
take a look at what happened with how do
I describe this without using jargon
there was this little shift in the way
that atoms emitted light called the lamb
shift lamb shift right so a slight
missed calibration between what you
predicted to what you saw exactly yeah
and at first people just thought it
would go away
and then as experimental techniques and
theory got better and better the
mismatch got more and more obvious until
it became clear there was a real problem
and this led to the development of a new
foundational theory of quantum physics
called quantum electrodynamics and this
is you know what the the single piece of
work that that Richard Feynman is most
well known for as well as Julian
Schwinger Nobunaga and Freeman Dyson
yeah exactly
and okay that I mean rupee fare that
that that could be classified as a
particular theory within the quantum
mechanical umbrella rather than the
foundations of quantum mechanics sure
that's true but if you were to asked
these people it had nothing to with the
measurement that's right it had nothing
to do with a measurement problem but it
certainly wasn't really applied short
right so if you ask those people you
know why aren't you paying attention to
the measurement problem they might have
said something like the theory works
very well this has all been worked out
and and we're focusing on real problems
not chasing phantoms so that's one
possible answer another possible answer
would be to say well what what
you mean they're they're you know rather
than to say the problems been solved
they would say no there was never a
problem there right it's not a problem
I you know they might take some version
of the Copenhagen interpretation and
really swallow it entirely and say no
really is all about these these
observations that we make that's really
all that matters I you know we're very
good at doing physics physicists are
very good at doing physics we're not
always good at describing how we're
doing over here yeah exactly
that's okay those who cannot do teach
and sometimes those who can do don't
know how to teach right exactly but but
but yeah I mean you know just the same
way that we deny oh you know things
outside of the realm of science have no
influence on science itself you can sort
of see somebody saying oh no no physics
is definitely all about the outcomes of
measurements and then you know they go
off and do something that's clearly not
about the no one ever said that before
quantum mechanics right I guess Mach
might have said that yeah much things
kind of like that there were
philosophers yeah and and Mach was both
a philosopher and a physicist sort of
yeah so yeah people people definitely
did say things kind of like that
beforehand in fact some people thought
that that's what Einstein had been
saying in 1905 when he came up with
special relativity and that was a big
inspiration for them though if you then
go back and take a look at Einstein's
other work from 1905 it's very clear
that actually that's not really the kind
of thing that he thought okay speaking
of which Einstein and also Schrodinger
who was sort of on his side they didn't
give up you know the post Solvay
conference and so and they're not giving
up was a huge boon to humankind in the
sense that they basically invented
entanglement right yeah I mean yeah it
forced the rest of the physics community
to understand that entanglement was
maybe the defining trait of quantum
mechanics you should tell us what
entanglement is yes that well so that's
another thing where no matter how I
describe it it's going to be picking
some interpretation
so so let me see what I can do make the
right yeah pick the right one clearly
yeah the the joke here of course is that
you have a preferred interpretation of
quantum mechanics and I just have an
anti preferred interpretation in quantum
mechanics but yeah so entanglement
quantum mechanics makes it very clear
that under really a wide variety of
circumstances you can have two things
that are widely separated particles or
whatever particles or whatever really
that you know despite the fact that they
are very far apart you know they could
be on other sides of the solar system
and despite the fact that there's no
obvious connection between them there
are instantaneous correlations in
experiments that you conduct on each of
the two of them and you can account for
that in several different ways and
that's another one of the things that's
at stake in this interpretation debate
right so the reason why Einstein
so yeah you see if two particles far
away quantum mechanics says that when we
measure them all we do is predicted
probability for getting certain outcomes
but what Einstein and Podolsky and Rosen
yeah say that the probability of getting
one thing is deeply affected by doing a
measurement on the other one yeah and if
they're really far away
exactly and sort of this seems to
violate at least the spirit of
Einstein's theory of special relativity
yes see why he'd be upset about it but
it doesn't actually let you send signals
faster than the speed of light or
anything like that yeah yeah you can
prove that you can't use it to send
signals like that you know they it's it
looks like an instantaneous influence it
doesn't look like something that you
could use for instantaneous
communication and so why did Einstein
think this was a big deal Einstein
thought this was a big deal because he
saw no reason to believe in any kind of
instantaneous influence he said well if
we really want to say that we can't talk
about what's going on before we make
measurements then we have to say it's an
instant
influence because you make a measurement
way over here and you make a measurement
way over there and they have correlated
outcomes all the time so if it really
you know if there was really no fact of
the matter before you made the
measurement then they must have been
conspiring immediately across great
distances or he said you could do the
reasonable thing and say that know when
you first sent them off in different
directions they already had a sort of
agreed upon set of properties and so
that lets you get around this without
saying that you know the two objects
have this sort of long distance
conspiracy going on so even though we
couldn't predict what our measurement
outcomes were the particles knew what
their measurement outcomes were going to
pay exactly so Einstein says given that
the two options are something totally
normal like that or this long distance
you know what he called spooky action at
a distance
he chose door number one and given that
those were apparently the two options on
the table at the time that seemed like a
reasonable thing for him to do and the
response that he received was not great
niels bohr Rota sort of famously
impenetrable response which he later
apologized for how poorly written it was
but then didn't really proceed to
elaborate on what he had meant I was
told that part of it was even printed in
the wrong order is that okay so right so
the printing in the wrong order this is
this is really inside baseball so I was
not originally printed in the wrong
order however in in you know the dark
days before the internet if you wanted
to find borz reply to the EPR paper you
you know the unsigned Podolski rosin
paper you had to go find it in a book
and the book where it was sort of most
famously and widely available was a book
from the early 1980s called I think
quantum theory and measurement it's a
big red book and in the first I think in
all of the first edition printings of
that book two pages of Bohr's reply were
swapped
and it's only like a four or five page
reply so that's a pretty big difference
and and the story which is I think
impossible to verify is that nobody
noticed for years yeah because I
couldn't understand it anyway yeah this
is make Lord of the pages are in and
also you know there's the Bors replies
sort of serve this very important social
function just by existing because people
could say oh you're not you know you
don't have to worry about that EPR thing
Bohr worked it out it's on that page and
so people didn't actually read it it was
just there but yeah you can now of
course download it online and and
whatnot but but a story that I know is
true because you know I don't know if
nobody noticed it it definitely was
printed in the wrong order when I first
read it I first read Bohr's reply I
guess it was 2005 so I did not have to
get it from that book I did get it from
the internet
I had the pages in the right order I
printed them out I read it and then I
went to the professor that I was working
with at the time I said you know this is
a really bad translation is there a
better translation available into
English because you know I thought oh
well you know Bohr wasn't a native
English speaker maybe this was written
in Danish and I see where this is going
yeah and then the professor told me no
no Adam in English yeah so yeah it's
just a fabulously impenetrable reply but
like you say it let the rest of the
community say oh yeah I know objection
and by the way I know science objection
was not quantum mechanics is wrong right
it was just that it was just a stepping
stone toward a bigger theory that we
would someday have exactly yeah he he
said that it was simply incomplete and
in fact I think that was the title of
the paper you know can quantum
mechanical description of reality be
considered complete not correct so ya
know people thought that Einstein was
wrong Einstein actually wrote a letter
to Schrodinger shortly after the EPR
paper came out saying that he had gotten
letters from you know couple dozen
different physicists from around the
world explaining why he was wrong and
none of them agreed with each other
so yeah I'm Simon Schrodinger sort of
laughing at everybody else behind their
backs Schrodinger meanwhile writes a
paper in support of the EPR position
saying look you know this is this this
long-distance connection this is a
fundamental property of quantum
mechanics it's everywhere and you can't
really get around it and to show you
another kind of example of the same
thing let's talk about a cat in a box
with radiation and a vial of cyanide and
so this is where this is where the
famous Schrodinger's cat thought
experiment comes from that's right and
so Schrodinger points this out as you
know he comes up with this thought
experiment to explain why there must be
some you know deeper fact about the
world or so he thought that quantum
mechanics doesn't capture because
otherwise you know maybe you can have a
particle that's not in any particular
state before you look but the
Schrodinger's cat thought experiment
says well if you have a particle in that
state you can set up an experiment where
a cat is neither dead nor alive before
you look and saying that a particle is
in you know a subatomic particle that we
have no direct experience with is in you
know neither one state or the other
that's one thing but cats are either
dead or alive yeah there are cats in
this apartment right now I haven't seen
them I am sure that they are either dead
or alive yes back there live yes yes
yeah but okay but just get the
philosophy on the table here yeah
Einstein and Podolsky and Rosen make
this point about spooky action at a
distance but they didn't just say and
that's obviously crazy like Schrodinger
with his cat his argument was really at
the level of that's obviously crazy you
don't believe that that's true that's
true no the EPR thought experiment in
that respect is more rigorous there was
a little more rigorous they what they
want to make the case that if you
believe that there really is something
actually happening at every location in
space in ways that you know they tried
to make carefully defined and so forth
then quantum mechanics couldn't be
complete and this is gonna skip ahead a
little bit but then
John Bell yes long and says that okay
Einstein is basically sketching out an
aspiration someday we'll have a better
theory that explains all this without
spooky action at a distance and bail
basically proved that no such theory can
ever reproduce the predictions of
quantum mechanics yeah bail people have
called bail the person who proved
Einstein wrong people have also called
bail the person who proved Einstein
right I think that neither of those are
really correct though I'm more
sympathetic to the second one because
what bail proved was that Einstein was
right to be worried right but that his
proposed solution couldn't work because
you can modify the EPR thought
experiment in this very subtle and and
you know brilliant way that it that that
will basically give you a real
experiment that you could build and the
results of that experiment if they
conform with the predictions of quantum
mechanics can't be accounted for with
this sort of pre-existing answers that
Einstein had in mind for how these
particles were you know arranging to
have these long distance correlations
right and bail so is an example of how
it was to try to do foundations of
climate so we're talking about like 60s
and 70s now and he was a perfectly
respectable particle theorist at CERN at
the laboratory where he discovered the
Higgs boson a few years ago mm-hmm and
correct me if I'm wrong but he basically
hid the fact that he was working on the
foundations of quantum mechanics from
his colleagues at CERN
he didn't I don't know why it is a
little bit advertising he certainly
didn't advertise it yeah you know there
is there is this nasty well nasty is
probably a list wrong there was
certainly whispers about John Bell at
CERN that you know oh he did something
important in quantum foundations but
don't worry about it because quantum
mechanics works anyway yeah don't hold
it against yeah exactly yeah
bells good friends who he worked with on
the other work he did not quantum
foundations bells sort of everyday
physics work was in quantum field theory
and one of bells good friends was
Martinez Veltman and and the story is
that Feldman
one day said to to Bell you know you did
this thing in the in quantum foundations
do I need to worry about this will it
affect my work in quantum field theory
at all and and Veltman is a very good
quantum field theory he won the nobel
yes he did prize yes and and so you know
Feldman asks Bell this question and Bell
says no don't worry about it it's not
gonna affect your work at all which is
true yeah and and so Bell yeah he
certainly didn't advertise that he was
working on this stuff he also didn't
work on it in a serious way a you know
great length until well after his career
was established and safe you know he
thought about this stuff in college and
then he thought about it a little bit in
early in his early graduate work and
then he was dissuaded from working on it
and so he put it off to the side and
came back to it later and a lot of
people even to this day there are
physicists who will claim that what Bell
proved was that you can't have what are
called hidden variables yeah that you
can't have secret new values secret new
parameters of physics that as Einstein
had hoped yeah would you know fix the
outcomes of future experiments even if
we human beings don't know about it yeah
but that's not what Bell proved in fact
we have to talk about David Bohm who is
certainly yes one of the more
interesting characters in the story yes
is yes so so no Bell certainly didn't
prove that you can't have these hidden
variables like Einstein wanted Bell
proved that you can't have
a particular kind of hidden variables
ones without spooky action at a distance
and and really what he proved was not
really about hidden variables at all it
was really saying that you can't have a
theory without spooky action at a
distance of some kind unless you break
something even more fundamental which
we'll get to it which we'll get to later
yeah exactly
my man whoever broke off yeah yeah no I
I think the way I described it in my
book is you know he showed that you
either have to have spooky action at a
distance or something even weirder yeah
but yeah so David Bohm right so David
Bohm was in a lot of ways the
inspiration for Bell's work and someone
who whose work Belle admired very
clearly David Bohm was a student of
Robert Oppenheimer the the guy who you
know was in charge of the Manhattan
Project though he himself only he didn't
follow Oppenheimer to Los Alamos why is
that well he didn't follow up in hybrid
a Los Alamos because David Bohm had been
briefly a member of the Communist Party
in Berkeley where he was doing his PhD
work and so when he applied for security
clearance to go to Los Alamos he was
denied that clearance they did not tell
him that this is why they denied him the
clearance they lied to him and told him
it was because he had relatives in
Europe who could be held as hostage
against him which while true in theory
was definitely not the real reason as as
you know documents uncovered well after
bomb died proved but um but yeah bomb
did do some important work that was
relevant to the Manhattan Project for
his ph.d which was promptly classified
and thus removed from his apartment
forcibly by military police because he
didn't have clearance to have his own
work and so it was a crazy time we're
talking about the early 40 yeah yeah
this is like
41 or 42 something like that maybe more
like 43 it doesn't matter the point is
it's during World War two it was a crazy
time like you said and and ya know hehe
didn't have any of his research notes
Oppenheimer had to go to the UC Berkeley
administration and say you have to give
him a PhD anyway just trust me which
they did which was good
boom had no problem with the Copenhagen
interpretation at this time you know
Oppenheimer was a great admirer of Bohr
Bohm was a great admirer of Oppenheimer
and so he didn't really think too
critically about it in and seemed to
work for him then he started teaching
quantum mechanics classes so teaching is
what's gonna get you in trouble clearly
clearly not usually supposed to this is
seen to have no shovel likes drawing the
foundations even when they teach one
that's fair that's fair Bolton was a
thoughtful guy yes Bohm was a thoughtful
guy he was teaching quantum mechanics
classes at Berkeley out of Oppenheimer's
research notes or sorry lecture notes
and then he got a position at Princeton
and continued to teach out of a mix of
his own notes and Oppenheimer's notes
and started turning that into a textbook
and that textbook he wrote was trying to
give the best version of the Copenhagen
interpretation that he could and make it
as clear as he could make it and in the
process of trying to do that Baum's
faith in the Copenhagen interpretation
just plummeted until by the end of the
process he was just completely plagued
with doubt the more you think about it
the less sense at me yes which I
certainly agree so then boom went and
met with Einstein who who had looked at
Baum's textbook once it came out and
sort of called Boehm into his office and
said look you you wrote this book and
you know how do you feel about it mom
said I'm plagued with doubt and Einstein
said look that's because you're trying
to defend an indefensible position you
you did the best
that you could do but no one can do it
because it doesn't work and so Boehm
walked out of that meeting thinking can
I find another way to look at this can I
find another way to think about quantum
mechanics and he did he independently
rediscovered a set of ideas that Louis
de Blois one of the other founders of
quantum mechanics had come up with back
in the late 1920s and then sort of
finished the work that de Blois started
and put together this theory which goes
by a bunch of different names bohmian
mechanics deploy bomb theory pilot wave
theory I like calling it pilot wave
theory because that's descriptive of the
content of the theory but mostly by the
way when deploy actually tried to
present his theory at the Solveig
conference and he was just hectored out
of his own theory exactly no good reason
yeah basically yeah I mean it is true
that the job wasn't done but he could
have finished it and he didn't yeah okay
yeah finished that took up that mantle
exactly boom took up that mantle puts
this thing together relatively quickly
and sends it off for publication the
problem is that at the same time that
all of this was happening booms past was
catching up with him he got called up in
front of the house on American
Activities Committee and testified in
front of it to to committee including
Richard Nixon who was a congressman at
the time and he was asked to name names
and tell people you know who the other
people in the Communist Party in
Berkeley during World War two were he
wouldn't do it he was held in contempt
of Congress he was arrested in his
office in Princeton and and by the time
he got back to campus after his friends
posted bail he had been suspended and
banned from the Princeton campus and he
was working on all of these ideas during
that suspension and year we talking this
is 1951 yeah
yeah yeah this is 1951 so so while he
suspended he works on these ideas about
quantum mechanics and then has his day
in court he's cleared on all charges
because it turns out that you know you
don't have to name names there's he had
fled the first in the fifth amendments
there there is a first and a fairly
common yeah exactly yeah
so he's cleared on all counts but
Princeton effectively fired him after
that and he couldn't get a job anywhere
else even though he had recommendation
letters from Einstein and Oppenheimer he
couldn't get work you know doing
academic physics anywhere in the US or
Europe much to his you know
disappointment finally he gets a
position in Brazil and so toward the end
of 1951 he goes down to Brazil and
shortly after arriving he's summoned to
the US consulate where they illegally
confiscate his passport and tell him
that he can only have it back if he goes
back to the United States which he
doesn't want to do because he's worried
that he's gonna be arrested again and
you know maybe you know brought up on
false charges or something so he's
trapped by now it's the height of the
Red Scare exactly it's the height of the
Red Scare and McCarthy era so I bomb is
is trapped in Brazil he can't get out he
was planning to go give a bunch of talks
in support of his ideas because his
papers were due to be published
imminently just a couple months later so
when they are finally published in very
early 1952 boom can't defend his ideas
through anything other than writing
letters to people and so mostly he's
just ridiculed you know someone
one of one of the quotes that I found in
my research for my book which I liked
the best was someone said that Bohm had
you know something the effective had a
very illustrious set of people sticking
knives in his bath all year long
in 1952 which yeah it's absolutely true
you know Wolfgang Pauli Verner
Heisenberg yeah these are that not the
political knives of being a communist
yes physics knives of like you're a
crazy person who doesn't understand
quantum mechanic exactly yeah but the
fact that he was a communist also didn't
help not only because he couldn't leave
Brazil but because at that time most
physics funding was coming from the
military and and it was the height of
the Red Scare and so if you know someone
in your physics department was suspected
of being a communist that could turn off
the faucet of funding and that's a scary
thing so yeah and basically to make it
very very brief his theory the
pilot-wave theory was the kind of hidden
variable theory that Einstein wanted
except rather than avoiding spooky
action at a distance it reifies it so
like the spooky action is doing all the
work here
yeah it's riddled with spooky action at
a distance I was a great quote from Bell
saying you know he resolved the EPR
paradox and the way that Einstein would
have liked the least
yeah something like that yeah it's it's
it's really another quote from Bell
actually about about bombs the theory
was that if you shook a magnet right
here it would instantaneously affect the
position of every single electron
anywhere in the universe which is not a
pleasant thing to consider as a
physicist doesn't mean it's wrong Isaac
no it would have been perfectly happy
exactly yeah Newton would have been fine
with it I mean obviously the influence
is very very small and and by the way
this this hasn't gone away like this is
this bohmian mechanics pilot-wave theory
is still one of the leading contenders
for a sensible interpretation of quantum
mechanics
not so much among physicists but among
philosophers and people who work on
foundations and what didn't you how
would you characterize the state of play
with reconciling these kinds of ideas
with quantum field theory and relativity
yeah I mean that the the fundamental
problem with
pilot wave theory bohmian mechanics
whatever you want to call it is that it
doesn't seem to play nice with
relativity for exactly these reasons you
know relativity doesn't have a preferred
frame of reference it doesn't let you
have things go faster than light bohmian
mechanics seems to violate that I would
have a much better answer to your
question about the state of play in
about three hours I'm getting dinner
with chip my collaborator yeah but we
rule out causality here in this podcast
yeah that's not sure that's not a
version of quantum mechanics be like so
information you'll get in the future
could not probably be this year so the
way that I like to put it I'm trying to
check reality check myself you're an
expert on bomi mechanics yeah people
have tried yeah to make it compatible
with relativity yes onam field theory
there have been yeomen like efforts yes
I don't think there's been anything
completely convincing I think that's
correct if you ask them why the problem
is there they will say something like
orally some of them will say something
like well quantum field theory actually
has its own foundational issues
independently of the measurement problem
in quantum mechanics which is true and
that makes it very very difficult to
come up with a you know bohmian
formulation of quantum field theory
because it's not clear what kind of
quantum field theory you want that can
account for all the different phenomena
that quantum field theory you know
accounts for I don't quite know what to
make of that it's a great example of how
non algorithmic physics really is yes
not the results you get from physics
with the process of doing it right yeah
you have all these sorts of puzzles
things we don't yet know the answer to
and some of them you have to say oh
don't worry
that'll be figured out whereas others
yet to say this is really important we
should really focus on solving this and
different people are gonna make
different choices exactly yeah no
physics is definite
lays subject to contingency and
personality and you know random fate 50
years the physics as a field made the
choice that the foundations were not
worth worrying about exactly and and
even now I'd say the standard position
is yeah don't worry about it you know
it's not as a rabbit as it was before
it's not you shouldn't worry about it
it's yeah don't worry about it as I'm
recording this I literally this week
just recorded the audio book for my
upcoming book something deeply hidden on
quantum mechanics so it seems
appropriate that I'm going to talk about
audible one of the leading services for
audiobooks magazines and more when you
become a member of audible you get one
audiobook every month and two audible
originals as well as 30% off regularly
priced audiobooks there's also of course
an app so you can listen to your audio
books at any time we have a special
offer for mindscape listeners you can
join audible with a 30 day free trial
you'll get your first audiobook and two
audible originals for free just go to
audible.com slash mindscape that's AUD
ible calm
/ - cape or text mindscape - 500 - 500
500 - 500 something deeply hidden will
be coming out hopefully September or
October on audible and you can have my
previous books from eternity to hear the
big picture and so forth they're all
available in audiobooks so happy
listening we don't need to talk too much
about Everett because yes it's my
podcast short the audience will get
plenty of Everett yeah over the years
but interestingly he was there at
Princeton yes in the early 50s - overlap
he was it ever was a student and Bohm
was an assistant professor yes that's
correct they didn't overlap they just
missed each other by something like two
years okay because I think Everett shows
up at Princeton as a grad student and I
want to say 53 or 54 and Boehm has gone
by the end of 51 okay so I wonder if you
know all of this in flew all this
work on quantum foundations at Princeton
in the early 50s wasn't ultimately
Einsteins fault
I mean Einstein certainly influenced
Bohm yes he apparently taught a class he
gave a lecturer that Everett was at
though Everett Everett doesn't remember
yeah he didn't remember later in life on
the other hand other people say that
Everett was there it makes sense that
Everett was there and also I don't know
ever it was a funny guy and wasn't
people forget things but yeah and it's
certainly a lot of sherry yes there was
a lot of alcohol of various kinds it's
absolutely true but yeah Everett
certainly read a great deal of Einstein
Everett also talked with Eugene Wigner
who was someone who was at Princeton at
the time who harbored his own kinds of
doubts about the Copenhagen
interpretation and so I think he was
definitely an influence on Everett and
probably vice versa and yeah Einstein
was there and you know the other thing
is Princeton at the time was one of the
best places to be doing physics in the
world or as much people would end up
there exactly yeah and and I think that
smart people are more likely to more
likely to question these truths that
they've just sort of been handed on a
platter which is not to say that if you
question those truths that makes you a
person okay I mean where there's a lot
of physics to get through here so yeah I
want to dwell too much on effort because
I was there otherwise but you know Boehm
suggested an answer to the measurement
problem may be out there were hidden
variables we just don't know their
values yeah and so measuring is
revealing some truth about nature that
we hadn't known before yeah yeah and
Everett suggests a completely different
one he gives up and and so what Bohm
gives up on is locality yeah that's
right he allows for spooky action at a
distance that's right yeah I mean it's
certainly a little bit more complicated
than
measurements simply reveal things that
were already there because measurements
can still influence things but it's it's
it's like it's a much less mysterious
process and so many mechanics is you
know harkens back to the classical
paradigm right where there are definite
values of things and we measure them
yeah in some ways of marketing yes
there's definitely some marketing yeah
it's true are as ever it takes
completely the opposite point of view he
says there's no hidden variables it's
just this wave function hmm you should
take it seriously there's not two
different ways of evolving there's only
one wave of all things yeah and the
price he pays is that when you measure
something the universe branches into
multiple copies yes yeah which is this
radical and deeply strange solution to
the problem but again deeply strange is
not a strike against a exactly yeah I
yeah and Bohm was chased out of the
country and then stabbed in the back yes
Everitt sort of took his golden
parachute right he didn't even try to
get a job as a physics professor yeah I
mean he was certainly not happy with the
way that his work was received
I mean Everett's mentor and an advisor
at Princeton was the great physicist
John Wheeler and wheeler was you know
one of Bohr's most devoted students and
so when he saw Everett's work he really
liked Everett's work at first but he
wanted it to get the blessing from the
master right to get the blessing from
Bohr and Bohr and I was never gonna yeah
that was never gonna happen born his
inner circle never gave hit that
blessing because of course they didn't
and the whole experience was definitely
you know a traumatizing one for Everett
but on the other hand Everett was never
gonna stay in academia
he wasn't my yeah it wasn't where his
passions were he wasn't chased down yeah
he wasn't chased out if he had wanted to
stay he might have had problems I don't
know I mean Wheeler was still willing to
go to bat for him but wheeler made
Everett make a lot of revisions to his
ideas in his pee
d thisis to try to make more happy it
didn't work of course and then ever it
did what he was always going to do which
is he finished his ph.d and went and got
a job working for the
military-industrial complex you know
doing essentially war gaming simulation
yeah exactly
bomb falling exactly yeah and okay so so
there is this sort of brief moment in
the 1950s when a couple people at
Princeton thought deeply about the
foundations of quantum mechanics yeah
and I it's fairly safe to say that their
efforts had zero impact for the next few
decades Oh didn't have big impacts for
for a decade or two yeah that's true I
mean and I'm also you know these are not
the only people who thought deeply about
the foundations of quantum mechanics
they're just the ones whose work ended
up being the most influential in the
coming years
but ya know people didn't that there
wasn't a lot of widespread you know open
talking about the foundations of quantum
mechanics there wasn't a lot of research
done on it you know the work that Boehm
did and that Everett did it was probably
the most notable work done in quantum
foundations at the time and then bail
shows up yeah
bail is one of these people who had
never been happy with the story that
he'd been presented with about quantum
mechanics and then you know he got into
fights with his college professors about
it and then shortly before finishing his
university studies in in 1949 shortly
before finishing college and he's in
Northern Ireland he's at Queens College
in Belfast I think the point is he's at
college he's almost done and then he
comes across a book by Max Born in which
Bourne describes a among other things a
proof from the great and mighty
physicist John von Neumann and John von
Neumann is is one of the Giants of 20th
century math and physics and so if
there's a proof of something by John von
Neumann it's almost certainly correct
and Orin says that von Neumann proved
that this way of understanding quantum
physics as as you know fundamentally
driven by you know chance that happens
you know like these weird random chance
events that happen when you make
measurements is the only way to think
about quantum yeah so it can't really be
deterministic hidden variable right
exactly there's there's no other way to
think about it and so Bell is very
impressed by this and he wants to go
look at the proof but he can't because
at the time it's only available in
German Bell doesn't speak German but he
thinks okay I'd better put this down
because von Neumann is is right and if I
keep thinking about this I'm just gonna
fall down a well and I'm never gonna
come out so he goes off and does some
work in accelerator physics and then
while he's working that job in 1952 he
sees the papers from David Bohm and he
reads these papers and he immediately
realizes there's nothing wrong with what
Baum said Bohm may not be right but it's
certainly a perfectly legitimate way of
looking at quantum mechanics and so then
Bell realizes well von Neumann must have
been wrong how can you prove something
can't exist when here's an example of it
exists right exactly so here's a counter
example so so he again wants to go look
at the proof it's still only available
in German so he goes off and works on
other things for a few years he goes to
graduate school he he suggests to his
PhD advisor that he could either you
know one day give a talk about either
you know bones work and the quantum
measurement problem or about accelerator
physics and his his PhD advisor never
gonna I never pronounce this name
correctly Rudolf Pyrrha Pyrrha 'ls yeah
yeah it doesn't matter the point is
well-known physicist another student of
Bohr or colleague of Bohr student of
Heisenberg said you know it basically
gave him a look and said why don't you
give a talk about accelerator physics
and so he just sort of left
yeah quantum foundations aside for a
while and then finally in the mid 1960s
he gets a chance to think about these
things and he sits down and looks at
Mahanoy man's proof which is finally
available in English along with a couple
of other proofs that are sort of related
and and he said you know I looked at von
neumann's proof and it fell apart in my
hands it's not just wrong it's silly I
clearly doesn't work and so he was that
he didn't he he made a mistake in the
proof or just didn't prove the thing
that people were saying if he didn't
prove the thing that people said finding
out and he also didn't prove the thing
that he thought he'd proven right you
know this this proof shows up in von
neumann's textbook quantum mechanics
textbook which is a really you know
incredible intellectual work with this
one flaw in it but in that book von
Neumann makes it clear that this is how
he's thinking about it and it's not
correct he hasn't proven when I session
was again I forget where maybe from your
book yeah Einstein who did speak German
had seen fun Newman's book and was at
least skeptical of this claim to prove
you know I talked about it to Bohm yeah
there are stories about that and I'm not
sure like the the stories about
Einstein's awareness of von Lehman's
proof are not particularly well sourced
okay
so I didn't put them in my book because
I didn't want deity good yeah and then
of course people attacked me from not
putting them in my book because no one's
ever happened but but the point is yes
Einstein may have been aware of it he
may not have been aware of it but even
if he was aware of it he was skeptical
of it but the point is von Lehman's
proof didn't prove what von Neumann and
especially a lot of other people thought
it proved and so bail works on it and
looks at that proof and these other
proofs that are sort of like it and
shows you know no they don't rule out
hidden variables that's not what they do
they do this other thing and Greta
Hermann knew it yes that's right
Greta Hermann a mathematician and
philosopher and student of Emme notre
pointed out the problem with von
neumann's proof just a few years after
he published it in 1935 and nobody
listened to her yeah nobody can a
variety of reasons probably including
the fact that she was a woman yeah but
they'll independently rediscovers these
problems also discovers the problems in
similar proofs that have been published
since publishes a paper basically saying
look you know these proofs don't do what
you think they do hidden variables are
still on the table they just need to
meet these requirements and then at the
end of the paper he says but there's
still the question about you know
theories hidden variable theories
whether they need to be like bombs in
that they need to have this nonlocality
that's an open question which somebody
should answer and so then he starts
working on that immediately afterward
right and then he answers at NIEHS is no
this nonlocality
it's a fundamental feature not just of
hidden variables but of any theory
that's going to reproduce the results of
quantum mechanics with the exception of
theories that break something even more
fundamental like many more like many
worlds like yeah so basically if
experiments have definite outcome yes if
experiments have definite outcomes and
there's not some vast conspiracy going
back to the beginning of time yes it's
that just in case the audience doesn't
know the buzzwords yes exactly so so
those are pretty much the only two ways
out now people are definitely not gonna
be happy with me for saying that but but
yeah you know you'll sometimes hear
people say no you can save locality if
you get rid of the hidden variables
that's not true because then you're
still left with Einstein's EPR argument
right then you'll hear like you already
said Bell's Theorem and his argument
wasn't really about hidden very about it
was about there's no way to reproduce
quantum mechanics without spooky action
at a distance yeah exactly
that's exactly right and you know you'll
hear people say but you can save
locality if you give up real
I have yet to hear a definition of
realism that satisfies that unless
unless you're giving up the idea of
things yeah in which case sure you can
have locality yeah people people do but
then you know what does locality even
mean yeah so yeah so so so let's uh you
know put ourselves where we are now so
we like the 60s or 70s most of the
physics community has been ignoring the
measurement problem of quantum mechanics
it was moment effort in the 50s but even
Boehm sort of didn't keep talking about
it a lot he distracted things I
remembered there's this quote from
yuckier Aronoff was one of his students
and together they invented the are on a
Bohm effect yes really really important
yesterday and someone asked him you know
Hirono did did you ever talk to Bohm
about his theory and now Hirono says no
we only ever talked about physics yeah I
hadn't heard that quote but that that
seems pretty plausible to me yeah I mean
he definitely he told me that when he
started working with Bohm they had an
agreement to not work on that stuff I
think in part because Bohm was worried
about what impact that would have on
Aronofsky ur and quite understand even
this infamous memo from the editor of
the Physical Review saying yes we won't
even look at papers yes foundations of
quantum mechanics yeah yeah which
someone later pointed out yeah he said
we're not gonna look at papers in the
foundations of quantum mechanics unless
they proposed a new experimental result
and or a new experiment that you can do
and someone pointed out well you know if
we had that policy thirty years ago that
would have forced you to reject Bohr's
reply to EPR yeah yeah yeah but yeah a
sign of the times though exactly yeah no
it was really bad so yeah in the 50s we
had Bohm and Everett in the 60s we had
Bell Bell's papers published he doesn't
hear anything about it for years part of
this is because there's this weird story
about where that paper and the other
paper he did before that were published
which is a whole thing that we're not
going to get into but yeah people just
weren't paying attention and then at the
very end of the nineteen
sixties Bell gets correspondence about
this paper for the very first time from
a graduate student named John clauser at
Columbia University who wants to conduct
an experiment to test this particular
set of outcomes of quantum mechanics to
see if Belle's proof holds about the
world because you know basically what
Bell showed was you can do an experiment
and if the experiment degrees if the
outcome of the experiment agrees with
quantum mechanics then you know you
don't have locality and if it does and
if it doesn't agree with quantum
mechanics then you can have locality but
also you've broken in quantity can be
both yeah the experiment couldn't show
that Bell was wrong Bell gave us horns
of a dilemma
exactly yeah either there's spooky
action at a distance or quantum
mechanics is wrong or yeah even worse
things like many worlds yeah yeah I can
experimentally figure out when we're on
yeah either either quantum mechanics is
correct in this outcome or we can have
locality so you have to actually do that
experiment and clauser wanted to do it
and so did a couple of other people and
so clauser got together with a guy named
Abner shamone II at Boston University
and a couple of other guys named horn
and Holt and they wrote a paper you know
sort of massaging bells result into a
form that could actually be tested
called the CH SH paper after their
initials this is always an
underappreciated part of the process of
burning the crazy things that the air is
do into something that can be
experimentally probe or at least
something that can be computed right but
yeah yeah exactly so they do this and
then in the very early 70s I think 71 or
72 clauser who at this point is a
postdoc at berkeley along with another
guy named Stuart Freedman actually do an
experiment to you know test
to test the predictions of quantum
mechanics in this in this situation and
they find that quantum mechanics works
surprise
yes surprise exactly yeah pretty much
everybody thought that it would clauser
was not sure those were really thought
that it might turn out the other way
and if it had he you know he would be
even more well-known than he already is
but yeah but but quantum mechanics
survived which meant that we couldn't
have locality with you know again in one
world yes not in one world yes so that's
been that idea of testing these things
has been upgraded and carried forward to
the present day that's worth some more
elaborate nests of bells inequalities
exactly yeah
so closer was first and then in the late
70s this guy named Al Ain a Spey did a
more did a more detailed experiment
testing again the predictions of quantum
mechanics in these conditions and found
again that quantum mechanics worked and
closer NS Bay really had very different
career trajectories from from that point
on closer when he did this he was a
postdoc he didn't have a permanent
position and he had a lot of trouble
getting a permanent position and and
ultimately never really did even though
he'd done you know this really
impressive experimental work so his his
career sort of suffered as a result of
doing this work ass Bay had a permanent
position before he did the work wise yes
and in fact when he'd gone to John Bell
to talk with him about doing this work
you know ass Bay met with Bell before
before setting out on this experimental
journey Bell wouldn't even talk to him
about it until as they assured him that
he had a permanent position because Bell
was so worried about damaging yeah you
know the careers of young physicists but
a spade did this experiment and then
went out and gave a lot of talks about
it and a spade is very good at giving
talks and indifference right yeah it
makes it very big difference so he's
very good at Gil's bore was very good at
convincing people a point of view and
Einstein you know for all genius kind of
just expected people to go along with
him he was not that good at the sales
pitches no he really wasn't he was not a
people person yeah yeah and and where's
Bohr almost had to work with people to
do his work Einstein almost never worked
with people or he worked with a very
small group of people he worked with
people in the EPR paper but then
afterward he never talked to Podolski
again yeah did not like he did not like
how that paper turned out and and I I
really think that that the clearest
versions of the EPR you know paradoxes
Einstein thought about our are in
Einstein's later writing where he really
explained it much more clearly but but
yeah so less pay was a big force in
changing how the field thought about the
foundations of exactly because he showed
hey you know he made people aware that
there was you know at least one really
nice experiment to be done in quantum
foundations and that in turn caused
people to take a look at Bell's work and
then when they did that all sorts of
interesting things happened not only was
there renewed interest in quantum
foundations but this also drove you know
the the the new field of quantum
information in quantum computing and to
be fair you know I do give people a hard
time the physics community I give them a
hard time for ignoring quantum
foundations but there is not only a
feeling that there's more interesting
things to be done but there was a
feeling that it's impossible to make
progress yeah on that kind of question
because it's more philosophy question
there's no experimental input etc etc
and and that is one way of changing that
is to do an experiment yeah it has a big
impact on this field exactly yeah
exactly yeah that that's exactly right I
mean I think you know as I was saying
before if the attitude of the physics
community was it's very hard to make
progress and so I'm not going to work on
because it's really hard that'd be one
thing that'd be fine the problem is when
you change that to this normative
statement when you say oh it's very hard
and you shouldn't work on it it's a bad
idea to work on it not just because
you'll suffer professionally but because
that's not the kind of thing that we do
as physicists mm-hmm and that certainly
endemic yes so in fact let's uh I guess
there's two big things I still have to I
still want to ask you about Iran is
despite all the bad-mouthing we've done
of the Copenhagen interpretation it's
sort of come back or at least versions
of it have come back in the form of
these epistemic approaches to quantum
mechanics there's a whole subset of
people who who really you know get
behind the idea that all we're supposed
to be doing all quantum mechanics
purports to do is to make predictions
for experimental outcomes well there are
definitely people who believe that and
there are definitely people who support
these epistemic interpretations
epistemic meaning that the wavefunction
is is about our knowledge about the
world rather than a thing in the world
but I wouldn't say that the people who
support these epistemic interpretations
are all people who say no we really
quantum mechanics is really only about
the outcomes of experiments and and we
shouldn't be doing more than that as
physicists I mean um someone we both
know
madly fer at Chapman University he is
certainly a supporter of these epistemic
interpretations but he he is a
scientific realist he thinks that there
is a world and there's stuff in the
world and the job of physics is to go
after that stuff he just thinks that the
that the quantum wave function isn't one
of the things in the world it's a
statement about our knowledge that's
right it's a very verification yeah so
we had this quantum wave function it's
the thing that you can't get away
without having in any version of
quantity yes and I think every that's
one of the few things everyone there's a
real hundred yes
Schrodinger's equation talks about the
evolution of something yeah but at least
there's a quantum state right there's a
quantum state well right but then but
amazingly we can't say in our best
understanding of the world whether that
thing is real
or just a tool yeah right and so the
epistemic folks want to say it's just a
tool it's it's just like a probability
distribution when when you say that I've
flipped a coin I haven't looked at it
yet yeah so is a 50-50 chance it's heads
or tails I can give a probability
distribution to that but there is a
reality beneath it yeah they want to
make the wave function like that yeah
yeah I think that's right
there are people who think that I don't
know there are positions that I I don't
know
now we're getting back to the subject of
people being angry with me there there
are people who hold positions that are
extremely Copenhagen like who will say
no the wavefunction is a statement of
our knowledge and there isn't a thing
underneath it well and proudly so right
there are people who identified
themselves as Copenhagen right
supporters not just because there's
nothing better but because that's the
right answer
exactly yeah and and and when you push
them on what do you mean by Copenhagen
you get a variety of interesting answers
and and one of the things that happens
is you get them sort of jumping between
mutually contradictory positions which
if you can pull that off is a really
effective rhetorical move because it
turns out that anything follows from a
contradiction so you can always answer
any question that you've been given you
just have to contradict yourself so
cubism is an example of an epistemic
theory it is do you know do you
understand cubism well enough to talk
about it for the audience this is
capital Q capital B ISM so quantum BISM
yeah quantum bayesian ISM yeah although
they now say that that's not what it
stands for and it's not clear what it's
just a name yeah so I think that this is
where I'm going to get people mad at me
for my book because I tried to be you
know I'm very Pro ever at pro
many-worlds yeah I tried as I said in
the book to be fair but not balanced
yeah so I certainly gave all of the good
lines to Eveready in quantum mechanics
but I tried to say correct things about
the other interpretations and cubism or
epistemic approaches more generally are
where the chances are greatest that the
proponents of those theories will not
think I'm being fair
I tried to be fair but I just can't
figure out what they're saying
so speaking of people being mad I I was
originally planning to have a chapter in
my book about epistemic theories and
then my editors started yelling at me
for being way over word-count which I
was and I ultimately decided you know
this is a book about the history of
quantum foundations and how we got from
where we were to where we are and these
epistemic interpretations or as I call
them in my book information based
interpretations because I try to use
less job now that's good probably smart
choice yeah I don't know that they like
it but whatever they're newish right
they they certainly have Copenhagen ich
DNA but they are mostly things from the
1990s and later they're young and being
developed exactly and so yeah exactly
and and so so I decided oh that means
that I can get away with not discussing
them a great deal because we haven't
seen how they're gonna play out yet and
and you know if you're writing a history
book that that tries to go up to the
present day the hardest part is always
gonna be the last 15 to 20 years yeah
and so I just kind of where we haven't
yet decided what history says exactly
yeah so I do mention that made my book
but I don't go into it in a great deal
of detail and and you know I talked with
Matt about this and he said yeah that
seems like a perfectly reasonable move
however some others sigh epistemically
some Cubist's or Cubist's whatever I bad
at pronouncing things are not happy
about that and they're also not happy
with how I present bore in my book and
you know whatever but I I have to say I
don't think that I really understand
their position terribly well either and
that could be me and but I'm not sure
that it is I have tried quite
bit to understand it although once I
realized that I wasn't gonna be going
over it in great detail on my book I
stopped trying as light as hard yeah
because I was working on the book but I
have since tried some more and and I'm
actually I'm going to have a chance
I hope later this year to sit down and
talk with David Merman one of the
Cubist's again but I I did talk with him
I had two long conversations with him
while working on my book he's someone I
know from when I was in college because
I he's at Cornell and that's where I
went for college he and and he's the
after mentioned professor who told me
you know gave me the bad news that no
there's not a different translation of
Bohr's paper so yeah David Merman is a
lovely guy he and I disagree about
quantum mechanics and I'm not sure that
I understand his position I I am not
sure what to make of Cubism okay that's
fine yeah that's that's perfectly fair
probably the most prudent thing you can
say I think that's right yeah yeah but
is it the other big point I wanted to
give it us a chance to talk about is is
the very fact of the existence the
resurgence the Renaissance of people
trying to make something like copenhagen
respectable hmm is it a reflection of
the fact that quantum foundations more
broadly are becoming slightly more
respectable in physics I mean you still
don't see look Caltech and Harvard and
Princeton are not gonna hire physicists
who study the foundations of quantum
mechanics says yeah you know senior
faculty members but yeah but maybe with
not only the experiments in quantum
optics and so forth but also interest in
quantum computing among information it's
become a little bit less objectionable
to worry about the foundations of
quantum mechanics yeah I mean I it
definitely has become less objectionable
I mean you know you've talked with David
Albert about this things are certainly
not the way that they were when he was
in graduate school right you know
I you know when I was in undergrad I was
curious about these things and I had
some professors saying why are you
asking these questions but there was
also David Merman who said yes ask these
questions and you know my PhD advisor is
certainly not someone who spends time
thinking about these things even though
he's a very very very good physicist and
very smart man but he doesn't mind that
I think about these things he just would
have minded if I had spent time doing
that rather than doing my research when
I was in graduate school and I didn't do
that so yeah I think I think that part
of it is just you know people look for
new options right people people come
into a new field or come into a newly
resurgent field and want to do something
new which is completely understandable I
also think some of it comes from an
understanding on the part of people who
are sympathetic to the Copenhagen
interpretation that if they want it to
survive they can no longer ignore the
competition so they're the you know for
many many years the strategy was what
alternatives right there are no
alternatives I did at one point I'm on
the colloquium committee at Caltech and
I suggested getting a talk on bohmian
mechanics and I was swiftly left down
with the withering gaze if that's a
mixed metaphor that I can get away with
yeah so we're not quite there yet
yeah situation might be improving a
little bit yeah yeah I think I think
that's right I mean on the one hand sure
that's true on the other hand people
have been inviting me to give physics
colloquia at you know some pretty good
places like I gave talks it wasn't a
colloquium but it was a public talk
sponsored by the Harvard physics
department Cornell's invited me back
Michigan's invited me back granted
that's because I went to both of those
places Michigan for my PhD but but still
those are good schools they're good good
physics departments
and other departments that I have no
affiliation with have also invited me
and you did not get Tomatoes thrown at I
did not get Tomatoes thrown at me I
thought I was going to get Tomatoes
thrown at me and I didn't you know I
gave a talk at Berkeley Lab which is you
know almost in my backyard and nothing
bad happened and they knew what I was
coming to give a talk about you know I
made it very very clear in the title and
abstract you know I was not saying you
know I'm not a partisan for any
particular interpretation I was just
saying hey the measurement problem is a
thing and it's it's an important open
problem in physics that doesn't mean
that everybody has to work on it any
more than anybody then you know
everybody has to work on any other open
problem right we wouldn't want that but
you should be aware that it's an open
problem you know the same way that
everyone's aware that we don't have a
theory you know we don't have a definite
well accepted theory of quantum gravity
right that's that's a well known open
problem even if you don't work on that
and relatedly maybe in fact part of the
reason why people have not been too much
in favor of thing about quantum
foundations is it it has the aura of
philosophy about it yes and you know for
those of us who think it's an important
problem that's a good thing yeah I mean
it's been probably with that in
statistical mechanics arrow of time type
stuff the foundations of quantum
mechanics of the area in which the
philosophers have in some sense carried
the torch for a while as physicist and
ignoring thing yeah yeah I think that's
right I mean the whole disciplinary
split between physics and philosophy is
a pretty modern invention you know we
used to call scientists natural
philosophers right Einstein and Bohr
would not have understood it exactly
yeah I you know it used to be that that
physicists generally had a pretty good
schooling in philosophy and certainly
didn't have outright contempt for it and
in less than a century we've gotten to a
point where many well-known scientists
and physicists do you have open public
contempt for philosophy and and you know
III do talk about that a little bit
toward the end of my book I'm really not
quite sure
why that happens I mean I've heard it
suggested that it coincided with the
shift in the center of physics from
Europe to the United States I think that
that's correct and I think that there
certainly Americans have always been
more down-to-earth practical folk
yes none of this abstract nonsense for
us we're gonna build things that is
absolutely true but but it's also not
true that you know there are no American
physicists who have you know
philosophical inclinations there always
have been some right it's I think
there's a lot of different sociological
things that went into it World War two
not only shift at the center of physics
to the US it also you know credit
created the era of big science and that
certainly had something to do with it
but but I'm still sort of puzzled you
know you get you get physicists saying
these things about philosophy and I
don't think you know sure we physicists
have have a deserved reputation for
being arrogant when it comes to looking
at other fields but I don't think that
you would get a physicist you know just
saying I don't understand why anybody
does I don't know sheet metal production
right that just seems like a silly thing
and you know anybody who studies best
practices and that is just wasting that
wasting their time right it's I don't
know anything about sheet metal
production but I do know that you know
it's probably good to do it in a way
that people don't get hurt right because
when you're manufacturing anything
people can get hurt that's why I'm not
an experimental physicist but well I
think you say I figure weathers in your
voice in your book or whether it was
you're quoting someone but there was
this wonderful idea that part of the
reason my name in Bell was it part of
the reason for the rejection of
philosophy and foundational questions
more generally was that most physicists
think that if they would just spend 20
minutes thinking about it they could
figure it all out they just haven't
found the time yet
that is indeed Bell yes yeah that's
exactly right well yeah no he was used a
really really good writer and speaker
well I hope that things are getting
better well you know we're on the same
side in terms of what
qualify is better but I do think that
slowly gradually it's getting there your
book I think definitely had a salutary
effect hopefully mine does and so too
and we're looking forward to whatever
book you end up writing next thank you
yeah so my Adam Becker thanks so much
for being on the podcast thanks for
having me
[Music]
you
[Music]